all right now let's keep the celebration
going with our week-long series with
country superstar thomas rhett
who was named entertainer of the year at
last year's academy of country music
awards and this year's
male artist of the year but thomas is
also a devoted husband and father to
three girls
and even has another one on the way and
it tells sangeeta being a dad
is one of the greatest gifts in life
when you get married and you don't have
kids it's like it's like how could i
love anything more than
your wife it's just a different kind of
love it's like literally you know the
whole phrase of like i take a bullet for
you
it's it brings so much more true you
know when you have children because
you're just like
geez like we we made you even when they
come home and they're like so and so
said this today you're like what's their
name you know
where do they live you know it just this
whole like protective like dad and mom
thing comes out on you and something
never thought you'd have but when you
have kids it's just indescribable
fatherhood even inspired thomas song to
the guys that date my girls
off his new album country again side
[Music]
what did you think of the song because
i'm a mother of two and listening to
this song was
just got to me she loved it immediately
was like do you think you're being too
harsh
to the guy in the song and i was like
not a chance
[Music]
so that was kind of a rough draft letter
you know to uh to the guys that are
eventually going to come to my house one
day and ask
you know take my kids out on a date and
am i going to be like his buddy am i
going to be kind of a
kind of hard or you know what was it
going to be especially for me having
girls i think you think it's 100 years
in the future when that's about to
happen but it's literally you blinking
it's gonna be here
i wrote that song in alabama last year
and actually played it in concert the
day that we wrote it
i was watching grown men just bawl their
eyes out
you know holding their daughters and uh
i was like dang if you can make grown
men cry you've done right